[Music]
getting a lot of attention cuz you go on
on tinder and and tinder of course the
social networking site that people use
for dating yeah it's it's like it's
anyone here on tinder don't lie to me
right now
yeah it's basically it's like uber like
you're able to date people within it's
like uber for just anonymous sexual
encounters basically is it really
because I'm obviously not in that world
but I don't know it's for its for single
people and all you do is see a photo of
someone and solely based on someone's
appearance you decide yes or no it's
like it's like OkCupid but like for
sociopath basically it's just off the
photograph just based on the photo you
make a decision yes or no and the photos
that people post are so insane like the
guys photos are nuts like guys are
posting photos of them like in the car
with their seatbelt on is what most of
the photos are on tinder which to me all
that says is that your wife is in the
house and this is the only time you have
[Laughter]
sketchy they're like these weird shady
photos there's photos of guys in front
of their cars like fancy cars to show
you know like they'll still be standing
in front of like a Mercedes or like a
Maserati
it's totally which all that doesn't tell
me that you is that you lease a fancy
car it's like we're gonna go to Chipotle
in a BMW I blew all my money right thing
this car for three hours 100% like
they're just a lot of photos of guys
with like tigers an exotic animal like
they're just all over the map
you bring cue you brought some because
you you write tweet these out you love
to find these photos and tweet them out
tell us what's your take on on this guy
this is what most of the photos on
tinder look like it's like a guy taking
a photo of his like tourists like his
like toned torso which to me if you show
photo of like how diesel and ripped you
are all that doesn't tell me that you're
unemployed these guts are always nice to
include a toilet ya always gonna snitch
always good to see a toilet in the
background and what about this one that
you said that there's a lot of guys oh
yeah tinder that have guns a lot of
photos of guys with guns which I don't
know what that is I don't know what that
says about like masculinity or something
in our all I know is that it turns me on
you want to be seeing more of that guy
what what about this one right here this
is enough this is actually tell us the
story behind it because this is real
guys like with girls like what he looks
like he's like at his engagement dinner
or something I don't know to me the only
thing I can ascertain from this is at
least she's not afraid of commitment
what if he's inviting a third person
into the relation I guess I can't do
threesomes
that's just like two people that don't
call me the next day with their
girlfriend and maybe it's from Mormons I
don't know I don't know I'm completely
confused by the whole thing and what
about this
now you see the status thing to me is
Stewart 45 that's bumming me out
a 45 year old spider-man bums me out I
think that's called a red flag this guy
I don't know I don't think he needs to
be on tinder I think he means to be on
Grindr explain what Grindr is later on
Noah grinder is right no who's gonna go
yeah
you